Caption: thanks to our sponsors hope you had a
Caption: good lunch and speaking of lunch play a
Caption: little game here let's say we're going
Caption: for dinner after the conference which
Caption: one would you go for so just I want
Caption: everyone of you to pick one give you 5
Caption: seconds to one ok easy enough right
Caption: now one last thing sorry if you're
Caption: healthy we're actually going to the
Caption: pizza place and if you could help me
Caption: take the orders and tell me which pizza
Caption: you would like to go with yeah so I
Caption: guess we've all been in this situation
Caption: before my name is Phil de Valence and
Caption: I'm the UX consultant I ratified and
Caption: we're going to look at some principles
Caption: those effects that influence the way
Caption: people perceive life and by extension
Caption: digital products psychology is central
Caption: to product development and that's
Caption: because product development is not about
Caption: products front development is about
Caption: people so if you miss the last few years
Caption: in software development we move from
Caption: what I call or we're moving from what I
Caption: call product centered design which is
Caption: quite easy you come up with your vision
Caption: of a product you push it down to users
Caption: if they get it you're a champion if they
Caption: don't they're a little bit stupid
Caption: moving on to human centered design which
Caption: as you can see is a little trickier
Caption: because people are context diverse they
Caption: are nonsensical at times and
Caption: understanding people is key to
Caption: understanding how to build good products
Caption: for those people to each once you're
Caption: gonna say that's cool because I am a
Caption: human so you should be okay right
Caption: well that's my mantra by the way it's
Caption: called the egocentric bias and it's it
Caption: says that we tend to overestimate how
Caption: our opinions beliefs
Caption: preferences values habits are normal of
Caption: other people now I'm not a trained
Caption: psychologist but psychology helps us
Caption: understand about bias we talked a fair
Caption: bit about bias today about perception
Caption: about emotions helps us understand about
Caption: social cognitive cultural influences if
Caption: we come back to our pizza menu that's an
Caption: example of the paradox of choice quite
Caption: well known or the choice of a load
Caption: now paradoxically if I give you no
Caption: options and I go we're all having a
Caption: Hawaiian pizza maybe if you are gonna go
Caption: yeah and maybe some other people are
Caption: gonna go I hate pineapple fair enough so
Caption: let's give people options after a
Caption: certain amount of options you get two
Caption: decision fatigue that's what I call the
Caption: baskin-robbins effect and I practice it
Caption: every week so apparently we make
Caption: according to a study by Columbia
Caption: University about 70 decisions a day but
Caption: another study says that if you can't
Caption: remotely conscious decisions it goes up
Caption: to 35 thousand decisions a day shall I
Caption: scratch my write that adds up limiting
Caption: the options is going to reduce the
Caption: cognitive load and cognitive load is
Caption: pretty much the amount of information
Caption: your brain it's your run to brains run
Caption: talking to experts yourself so this law
Caption: is known as Hicksville it's very simple
Caption: and a lot of what we're going to talk
Caption: about today is common sense the thing is
Caption: we need to know when to apply it to
Caption: building product and that says that the
Caption: more choices you have the longer it
Caption: takes to make decisions now I was on
Caption: this music mastering platform a year ago
Caption: it was quite different to that that's
Caption: what it looks like today I couldn't find
Caption: the screens but each one of those
Caption: pricing tiers
Caption: would lead to a page with another four
Caption: of five pricing tiers that was 16 to 20
Caption: pricing options on different pages I
Caption: might yeah I was going to go to an OA
Caption: another product another website I wrote
Caption: to them instead now they've got fortunes
Caption: and I believe it's thanks to me we all
Caption: do that right it could be better with
Caption: the bond rest of effect or also known as
Caption: the isolation effect so when you have
Caption: multiple multiple similar objects the
Caption: one that stands out that's different is
Caption: going to be more easily remembered now
Caption: you may say we don't want people
Caption: necessarily to remember our user
Caption: interfaces or the layouts of our
Caption: products but if it's easy to memorize
Caption: it's also easier the next time you come
Caption: to find your way around it if we use
Caption: another pricing table here
Caption: you can see that one of them's been
Caption: highlighted as recommended if you go
Caption: back to the pizza place can help if the
Caption: waiter goes well our special we're
Caption: really good at it is the margarita and
Caption: you're gonna go yeah or maybe not but
Caption: that reinforces your decision another
Caption: takeaway would be to have clear action
Caption: buttons in your interfaces and not only
Caption: but also menu highlighted menu item
Caption: talking of cognitive load what do you
Caption: see here a lot of dots well the the law
Caption: of common region says that elements tend
Caption: to be perceived in two groups in groups
Caption: if they are sharing an area with a
Caption: clearly defined border so it's very
Caption: simple again but unless you do that you
Caption: go from a big mess to something that's
Caption: more manageable very close to that no
Caption: pun intended is a lot of proximity which
Caption: plays the key the same that using white
Caption: spaces using elements in different
Caption: spaces a takeaway for this is well for
Caption: example if you mix important content
Caption: with ads for example in the same area
Caption: people may think your content
Caption: is an ad another two quick takeaways on
Caption: the left one of those beautiful IT parts
Caption: websites with about 150 items without
Caption: any kind of structure on the left and on
Caption: the right you can see things have been
Caption: chunked together and you may wonder how
Caption: much is too much
Caption: actually when what is manageable and
Caption: what's not
Caption: well there's a lot for that it's millas
Caption: low and mills low you can take different
Caption: ways but basically it says the average
Caption: person can keep seven items in their
Caption: working memory I know you're not the
Caption: average person maybe you can go to 1450
Caption: or if you're Rain Man many more but the
Caption: reality is seven plus or minus two
Caption: there's another side to it at any moment
Caption: you can detect about seven objects in
Caption: your environment
Caption: that is useful for example if I'm
Caption: designing website I'm going to make sure
Caption: the main navigation the main menu
Caption: doesn't go away over seven eight nine
Caption: items if not I'm gonna think about my
Caption: architecture again oh sorry
Caption: someone act into my slideshow
Caption: well it won't happen again
Caption: oh I hope it will did you know that in
Caption: the 70s people thought it was okay for
Caption: computers to take approximately two
Caption: seconds to respond to user input well of
Caption: course there were technical restrictions
Caption: back in the days but still they thought
Caption: that with two seconds users could plan
Caption: out the next task and as technology
Caption: evolved a gentleman called Walter
Caption: Doherty of IBM you notice that computer
Caption: performance improved as computer
Caption: performance improved there was a massive
Caption: increase in productivity and also
Caption: employees got more satisfaction from
Caption: their work and work quality tended to
Caption: improve so the hurt is threshold is
Caption: actually a number it's 400 milliseconds
Caption: it's not you know maths but if you keep
Caption: that interaction to a minimum that's
Caption: when you get that result now a little
Caption: challenge I would love for all the
Caption: websites in the world to load under 400
Caption: milliseconds the average time for
Caption: websites to load on mobile today is 22
Caption: seconds Google's strive to go under half
Caption: a second with all their products it's
Caption: good to have challenges in life now on
Caption: to Jacob slow you may have heard of
Caption: Jakob Nielsen music Norman group handing
Caption: out UX certifications these days very
Caption: active he's been around for a long time
Caption: and he's always quite cute actually says
Caption: that users spend most of their time on
Caption: other people's websites which means that
Caption: when they get onto your website they
Caption: would appreciate for things to work the
Caption: same way as they do on other people's
Caption: website I can feel a bit of a rant I
Caption: don't know but let's take a metaphor
Caption: have you ever driven a car where the
Caption: indicator is is on the wrong side of the
Caption: steering wheel very funny the first time
Caption: not as funny the third or fourth but
Caption: sometimes you need to make a difference
Caption: between creativity and usability right
Caption: you need to
Caption: know the rules before you can break the
Caption: rules and if you're reinventing the
Caption: wheel well make sure that it's better
Caption: than the will if not what's the point
Caption: really have you ever been on a forum
Caption: like this where the very cleverly put a
Caption: reset or clear button where everybody
Caption: else puts a Save button oh yes on two
Caption: feet slow very simple the time to
Caption: acquire a target is a factor of the
Caption: distance to the target and the size of
Caption: the target now I would have you a lot of
Caption: us in this room are pretty handy with
Caption: the mouse I would even argue maybe some
Caption: of us are gamers well not everyone is
Caption: and there's a few rules to know we're
Caption: not going to go through every one of
Caption: them are just going to illustrate that
Caption: with an example with 44 points minimum
Caption: size on a touch device but also
Caption: something like this for example
Caption: personally I use keyboard shortcuts I'm
Caption: not going to try and click on that thing
Caption: the mouse is really far from there now
Caption: after jacobs low Millett slow feet slow
Caption: this one is really the most important of
Caption: all and the one I want you to remember
Caption: cottesloe want one happen again no the
Caption: next one is actually very cool because
Caption: it's got the word cocktail in it it's a
Caption: cocktail party effect imagine you had a
Caption: cocktail party there's a lot of noise
Caption: music everyone's screaming on top of
Caption: their heads voices and you're trying to
Caption: have a conversation well your auditory
Caption: senses do something that's really crazy
Caption: they actually cut off any external noise
Caption: so you can try and focus on the person
Caption: that's talking to you
Caption: well that text Todd tells us about our
Caption: ability to focus our attention also to
Caption: switch our attention because sometimes
Caption: really I'm pretending like I'm talking
Caption: to someone but I'm listening to much
Caption: more interesting conversation behind me
Caption: don't tell me you've never done that a
Caption: take away if you look at this page the
Caption: first thing you you think is probably
Caption: yeah but the second thing is what what
Caption: is the goal what's the aim here what
Caption: where do we go and another thing is
Caption: really banner blindness there's a lot of
Caption: things that look like ads which means
Caption: people are not going to look at them
Caption: because they aren't I was talking about
Caption: Jakob Nielsen Nielsen Norman group did
Caption: studies in the late 90s and then 10
Caption: years later and then a couple years back
Caption: where they go that people absolutely
Caption: ignore the ad even though the sneaking
Caption: UX designer MIT made that ad look
Caption: exactly like the rest of the content now
Caption: I'm not looking at it when they look at
Caption: ads then they repent and never look at
Caption: it again it's studies prove it over and
Caption: over again I'm not saying we don't need
Caption: ads I mean there's financial realities
Caption: but how do you get people's attention
Caption: that's an example of selective attention
Caption: by the way well one way is the serial
Caption: position effect so we have found out
Caption: that people best remember the first and
Caption: last item in a group of items
Caption: journalists know that for example and I
Caption: would say one takeaway for us content is
Caption: not to distill your important
Caption: information in the middle of the
Caption: paragraph no one reads on the web come
Caption: on you don't believe that except for the
Caption: terms and conditions of both but no one
Caption: is anything like they just skim through
Caption: so if you don't start with the point you
Caption: may lose the point 10 the authority
Caption: principle humans tend to comply with
Caption: people in positions of authority or
Caption: perceived Authority so can be physicians
Caption: can be policemen can be lawyers or
Caption: experts and that can lead to an ethical
Caption: behaviors like spamming for example hey
Caption: I'm the police give me your money
Caption: but it can also be used for the greater
Caption: good altogether the greater good okay
Caption: I'm the only one that seen that movie
Caption: them alright this website passion
Caption: planner use it in two different ways on
Caption: this page one with Amazon's review
Caption: system which is quite well known and
Caption: established and you know in general it's
Caption: not like two or three people voted or
Caption: reviewed so that's one usage of that but
Caption: also the Business Insider quote the best
Caption: planner overall you've got to understand
Caption: the Business Insider websites for we
Caption: ranked on Alexa 300s while fashion
Caption: planner is in the hundreds of thousands
Caption: so you can use photos of people in
Caption: uniforms logos symbols badges quotes
Caption: okay
Caption: a little special yeah one over ten
Caption: there's actually many more lows that ten
Caption: with psychology but I took the liberty
Caption: this one I call though where the heck
Caption: are you taking me effect now the other
Caption: day a colleague of mine told me how they
Caption: got on a train at the right station at
Caption: the right time on the right line and
Caption: five minutes into the journey I'm not
Caption: saying they weren't a little bit drunk
Caption: but five minutes into the journey they
Caption: realized they were going south well they
Caption: wanted to go north okay well that
Caption: reveals something one it's quite
Caption: unpleasant to be on a journey without
Caption: knowing the destination it can be
Caption: exciting but a lot of times in digital
Caption: products it is unpleasant another thing
Caption: that can be unpleasant is to be on a
Caption: journey to a well-defined destination
Caption: that that's basically why we here but
Caption: for some reason it's like you took an
Caption: uber from Perth to Fremantle and you
Caption: you're wandering through the streets of
Caption: jungle of like man what are you doing
Caption: what are we doing here and it's kind of
Caption: a parallel
Caption: I'll make again back to the pizza shop
Caption: you know like oh you want a margarita
Caption: cool would you like fries with that you
Caption: go oh that's cool yeah why not then
Caption: would you like a massage with it oh you
Caption: know an insurance policy is like get out
Caption: of here give me my pizza now my point is
Caption: users very kindly offers something very
Caption: precious which is their time and their
Caption: attention but we shouldn't abuse it and
Caption: take them on journeys that they are not
Caption: here for they're not sign up for it and
Caption: basically it's gonna piss them off a
Caption: take away from this law of where the
Caption: heck are you taking me is it's always
Caption: good to use a progress indicator on
Caption: paginate it forms for example but I'm
Caption: also thinking at a much higher level in
Caption: the products architecture in the
Caption: navigation in the flows to always
Caption: indicate clearly the destination in the
Caption: itinerary where you are on the map now
Caption: we've seen a few points like I was
Caption: saying there's many more but a few
Caption: takeaways you will notice they go
Caption: towards simplification that's one
Caption: important thing that less is more
Caption: avoid unnecessary elements or tasks
Caption: minimize choices chunks elements
Caption: together you need to do the hard work
Caption: not the users use consistency respect
Caption: the users but another one would be to
Caption: test test your interfaces test your
Caption: products regularly it's a two-way
Caption: conversation with the users why
Caption: technology evolves the technology six
Caption: months ago is different to technology in
Caption: six months you cannot rely on studies
Caption: done two years ago in certain areas
Caption: things have changed dramatically so not
Caption: only technology evolves but people
Caption: evolve society evolves if you want to
Caption: dig a little bit deeper you've got the
Caption: gift all principles that you can look up
Caption: also this amazing website loads of UX
Caption: dot-com which inspired some of our
Caption: designs here they actually come with
Caption: those beautiful posters you can hang
Caption: around your house and your partner will
Caption: love it
Caption: but remember that you are not the user
Caption: and thank you
Caption: [Applause]